I've built a 20 million net worth I've
been full-time in property for 15 years
I've done over 500 property deals and in
this video I wanted to share how you
actually get rich because I see a lot of
people talking and even writing books
and doing YouTube videos that have maybe
done a few deals I've done a lot of
deals I'm going to share from my
experience the five levels to richness
the five levels that you're going to
have to go through certainly that I went
through to becoming super successful in
property and in business certainly
financially so the first level is just
immersing yourself in learning I when I
was 16 years old I dropped out of school
age 16 I just threw myself into learning
I worked on a building site for 6 weeks
learning to like plaster understanding
construction I worked in an estate
agency I went on every single training
course I could find many people laughed
at me cuz some of the courses I spent
quite a lot of money I spent quite a few
thousands going on courses and my
friends and family were like what are
you doing going on these getrich quick
property investment courses and I'm
thinking well you're going to University
you know it's it's all right to go to
university and get into tens of
thousands of pounds into debt to learn
about geography or to get a degree in
drama because it's backed by the
government but now I'm learning about
property investment and I'm learning
from actually people that have made
millions of pounds and I'm spending
money going to networking dinners and
events and I'm getting mentors immersing
myself in how to actually get rich
people are all worried about me and
interesting it's okay to go to
university and spend £30,000 getting
into debt to learn from a guy who gets
paid £30,000 a year so that one day
hopefully you can get a job and you can
make £30,000 a year that's okay so what
I would say is first first level for me
was immersing myself in the knowledge
and I also believe that education in
property and in business it's important
to learn but you've got to do at the
same time the only way to truly know
something is to do it if you're at
University I'm not knocking University
but if you're at University for 5 Years
Learning the theory of real estate you
ain't getting to actually understand
real estate if you're try learning about
business and it's all theoretical and
you're doing exams learning about
business it's not real so immerse
yourself in in education read books
attend seminars but actually do it work
for people for free you know get on the
construction site go and work as
apprentice at an estate agency really
immerse yourself in learning come go to
all the seminars you possibly can
understand the the lingo so that's the
first stage second stage and there's
five second stage is being the
entrepreneur so to begin with in
property I started out with very very
little money okay how could you be a
property investor when you haven't got
any money to invest the answer is it's
kind of hard so this the stage two is
being an entrepreneur so thinking how
can I make cash how can I make quick
cash in the property space learning and
understanding the business without
actually investing money and the ways
that I did it were things like Property
Management so I would find um investors
got big portfolios that grow in their
portfolio and I'd say listen how many
rooms I know you've got you've got hmos
you've got all these rooms how many of
them are empty and they go oh my
goodness loads you know I've got um 500
rooms and I got 80 rooms that are empty
I said interesting if I can come and
fill those rooms and find tenants for
them will you give me a commission will
you give me a finders fee every tenant I
can find you I mean what investor is
going to say no so so now you got an
invest yeah man if you can find me 80
tenants to film 80 rooms I'll pay you
you know £500 per tenant you find me now
cool now go and create a a spare room
advert and start showing people around
get the keys and that's not being a
property investor but that's called
being a property entrepreneur now I'm
getting £500 every time I'm finding a
tenant for the investor which is paying
my roof over my head but I'm also
immersed in the game I'm learning um
deal sourcing finding investors and
saying what are you looking for what
kind of properties you looking for oh
I'm looking for some you know flips some
rundown properties in London that I can
do up and sell interesting if I can find
you a property would you give me a
finders fee 2% commission now again I'm
not being a property investor I'm being
a property entrepreneur so stage two of
my journey was about being a property
entrepreneur was about finding deals
hustling making a living but also
getting myself amongst the right people
so stage one is immersing yourself in
education stage two is about being a
property entrepreneur stage three is
about buying your first house see my
first house that I bought was 21A maral
Road in bourneville Birmingham I bought
that uh March 24th
2009 the feeling I got from being a
homeowner as a teenager not just a
homeowner but owning a house that I'm
renting out room by room and making
1,000 a month profit from like the buzz
that you get from actually owning
something and this is the interesting
thing as well when you own a house and
it's your first investment property and
it's an asset not a liability some
people own houses but they live in the
house and it's not making them any money
it's not as exciting when you own a
property The Leverage you get from that
house like I bought that first house for
£100,000 it's now worth around £300,000
so it's gone up right it's doubled in
value like almost like two times but
here's the thing if you buy a house if
you put down a small deposit if you put
down 10 grand and you buy a house for
100 grand if that house doubles in value
and goes up to 200 Grand you've made
you've not doubled your money right you
only put down 10 grand so you put down
10 grand but the house is 100 Grand but
now the house is 200 Grand you've 10x
your money and hous is historically
double in value every 10 years so stage
three is about saying now I want to
start owning stuff someone once said
don't wait to buy property buy property
and wait and when you own property and
you're sitting on it the freeold there's
a limited certainly in the UK limited
amount of land we're on a tiny Island
and that we're in a huge housing crisis
because there's a massive shortage of
housing there's an overpopulation of
people in a shortage of houses basic
supply and demand rents are going up
like mad even when we're in a recession
right now we're in a recession what's
happening to rents they're going up like
mad they've just hit ,000 a month on
average rent across the country so
owning a house not only does it give you
a sense of satisfaction and is it giving
you an asset that's producing cash every
month that you can sit on as going to go
up in value but it's also going to help
you for stage four cuz stage four is
about using other people's money to grow
your portfolio proper leverage it's much
easier to do that when you own houses
yourself if you can say I understand the
crack I've been in property a long time
I've worked on Builder sites I've worked
as a letting agency oh and also you know
I own that house there that I'm renting
at room by room and I found this deal
and it's brilliant and all I need is a
partner cuz I want to share the profits
with somebody now so if you've got some
money we can do a partner ship if you
can get people to agree to that they
they trust you cuz they can see your
experience then you can blow up stage
four and stage four is finding houses
not just owning a house but owning
properties that are run down where you
can push the value up I mean this is
what we mainly focus on the property
investors crash course I run a program
called the property investors crash
course which is like a one-day intensive
program and basically the majority of
the day is just me with a computer
finding deals finding deals and once
people have seen me finding deals once
you've seen it you can't unsee it and
you're okay that's how Samuel finds
deals then on the property investors
crash course then I'm like your turn get
your phones out get your laptops out so
it's incredible day if you've not been
on the property investors crash course
that's where it all starts I'll leave a
link in the bio and by the way cuz I'm a
nice guy tickets to the property
investors crash course are1 okay1 spend
a day with me I'll leave a link in the
description stage four is about buying
houses where you can push the value up
don't wait for the value to go up
capital appreciation doesn't pay the
bills you can't sit on a house and just
go I'll just wait for it to go up in
value because historically it does what
stage four is about is about buying
properties run down houses maybe
properties of Japanese not Weir
structural issues it's uninhabitable not
only if you got huge tax advantages if
it's unhabitable because you don't pay
stamp Duty tax or anything like that but
also you can buy it cheap then you can
push the value of the house up by fixing
the structural issues by getting rid of
the Japanese not weed and getting some
insurance in place now you bought a
house for 100 you spent 50 Grand on it
sure but now it's worth 200 now if it's
worth 200 what do you then do you then
get a new mortgage and how much can you
get 75% loan to value not loan to
purchase loan to value you change the
value of the house therefore you change
the loan that you can get so you buy it
for 100 spend 50 on it now it's worth
200 now you get a new mortgage for how
much 150 that means that you get all
your money back and it wasn't your money
anyway it was an Investor's money so you
pay the investor back the investor gets
all their money back and the investor
gets 50% of the house and you get 50% of
the house this is stage four this is is
a bit hard this is more complex there's
more there's more to it uh stage one is
easy just learning stage two you know
being an entrepreneur making a bit of
money hustling that's cool everyone can
do that so be buying a house and getting
that sense of accomplishment I did it I
love that on the crash course I have I
get so many messages like a week after
the crash course two weeks 3 weeks after
the crash course coming in I just found
a house I just bought a house then the
messages keep coming in I've completed I
got the keys and you see everyone DK all
I see on my Instagram is people dangling
Keys thank you Samuel it all starts at
the crash course but stage five it gets
real tricky stage five is where you get
super rich and this is the stage that
I'm still at now I've been in for many
years now stage five is property
development stage five is buying rundown
pubs factories and splitting them up and
slicing dice convert them into
affordable houses stage five is buying
land I've got uh six pieces of land that
I'm currently building on buying land
and building houses not only will this
make you the most money byy a mile but
also the government love you because the
government they know that we've got a
shortage of houses so there's loads of
advantages tax advantages but also when
you're working with the government as
opposed to against them a lot of
property investors because they're
amateur they don't know what they're
doing they feel like the government are
fighting them oh tenant eviction bans
and tenants rights oh it's really
difficult to be a landlord if you do it
the right way cuz here's the thing the
people that make up the rules the ones
in charge they make money in property
themselves so if you understand how to
do it the right way and go with the rich
then not only can you make a lot of
money but also you're swimming in the
right way of the tide so it's a lot
easier so anyway I hope you found that
useful that's my story
if you want to spend a day with me as I
mentioned I'll leave a link in the
description you can spend one day with
me at the property investors crash
course I'm going to be touring across
the uh across the country so it's 1 come
and spend a day with me link in
description thanks for watching